[Music]
many of us
are familiar with lego bricks that
children play with to construct
buildings and figures thanks to recent
scientific developments
scientists have developed something
similar an atomic scale lego set
made of 2d materials a 2d material
consists of a single layer of atoms or
molecules
since the discovery of graphene a single
layer of carbon atoms
scientists have made many other
two-dimensional materials with a broad
spectrum of physical properties
from insulators to semiconductors to
superconductors
with a library of 2d materials at their
disposal
scientists can assemble them like legos
creating an
atomic scale lego set the 2d materials
link through weak electrostatic
attractions
known as van der waals forces by
combining 2d materials
scientists can build structures to
improve the performance of electronic
devices
create materials with novel physical
properties and discover quantum
phenomena
transistors are a fundamental component
of electronic devices that control
electrical signals
nanoscale transistors can be
manufactured using 2d materials
which require a flat surface to achieve
optimal performance
scientists demonstrated that an atomic
flat surface can be made by layering
2d material transistors on sheets of
hexagonal boron nitrate
and insulating 2d material these 2d
material transistors built to extreme
thinness
offer a promising platform to build
computers with enhanced power
such as quantum computers resulting from
the restricted range of motion and
electron experiences
2d materials exhibit unique physical
properties
this can be understood by thinking of
electrons as cars
in 3d objects electrons are like flying
cars that can avoid each other by moving
through vertical space
electrons in two-dimensional materials
however are in constant gridlock
because one electron's movement directly
influences another's
as a result the physical properties of
2d material
are dominated by the nature of electron
interactions
the atomic scale lego set allows
scientists to take advantage of these
strong interactions
to assemble structures that exhibit
novel quantum phenomena
for example by coupling two graphene
layers in close proximity
scientists have observed for the first
time in 2d materials
a phenomenon of super fluidity in which
fluids flow without friction
by stacking and twisting 2d materials
not only are different materials
interacting in new ways
structures made of the same material are
being arranged in patterns not possible
in nature this is uncovering physical
properties
that the periodic table doesn't predict
for example
scientists recently showed that a new
type of solid structure called
amoria super lattice can be formed by
rotating two monolayers
relative to each other when the
rotational angle is small between
two 2d layers a fractal structure known
as
hofstadter's butterfly emerges at
several special angles
this fractal structure strongly modifies
electronic behaviors
unlocking new material properties one of
these angles
the so-called magic angle reveals a
superconducting phase at low temperature
superconductors can reduce the amount of
energy converted into heat in electronic
devices
and create powerful electromagnets which
have potential applications in
transportation
medical devices and telecommunication
by choosing building blocks from a large
family of 2d materials
scientists now have endless
opportunities to create future materials
with novel physical properties
which promise to transform everyday life
you